قال مسؤولون اسرائيليون ان وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه رون ديرمر سيصل
واشنطن اليوم الثلاثاء لعقد اجتماعات مع
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن ونقل موقع اكسيوس
عن المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ان نقاشات
الوزير الاسرائيلي ستتناول خطط تقليص
الحرب والانتقال الى عمليه المنخفضه الشده
في غزه واوضح الموقع ان الوزير الاسرائيلي
سيلتقي بمستشار الامن القومي جيك سوليفان
ووزير الخارجيه انتوري بلينكن واعضاء في
الكونجرس كما نقل اكسيوس عن المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين انه من المتوقع ان تبدا تل
ابيب بخفض عمليتها في غزه بحلول نهايه
يناير واوضح ان ديرمر سيناقش ايضا مع
المسؤولين الامريكيين افكار رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو فيما يتعلق
بحكم غزه بعد الحرب فيما نقل اكسيوس عن
مسؤول امريكي ان القضيه الرئيسيه للمناقشه
بين اداره بايدن وحكومه النياه حاليا هي
كيفيه انهاء الحرب وفي اي اطار زمني فقد
بدا المسؤولون الاسرائيليون يتحدثون مؤخرا
مع اداره بايدن عن حكم السلطه الفلسطينيه
لغزه بعد اصلاحها بعد ان كان نتنياهو يرفض
الفكره بالمطلق وفق ما ذكر
الموقع معنا لمتابعه ذلك من واشنطن
الدكتور حسن منيمنه المحلل السياسي
والباحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن
دكتور حسن ه هذه مره المبعوث اسرائيلي الى
واشنطن اخر زياره كانت اخر مبعوث كان
سوليفان الى اسرائيل لم تحقق زيارتها
انذاك النتائج المرجوه هل تتوقع ان يكون
هنالك تغيير بعد هذه الزياره ل الوزير
ديمار هو تابع للكور طبعا بطبيعه الحال
لنتنياهو
الطرف الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى تبديل في
المواقف الامريكيه والاسرائيليه ليس من
داخل اسرائيل ولا من داخل الولايات
المتحده وقطعا الصمود الفلسطيني على الارض
اقول هذا لاننا خلال الاشهر الماضيه راينا
مد وجذر في المواقف الكلاميه الامريكيه
فيما يتعلق بكيفيه معالجه المساله مساله
الحرب تحديدا ومساله ما بعد الحرب وراينا
تجاوبا وتراجعا من الجانب الاسرائيلي في
هذا الصدد ولكن فعليا على الارض لم يتبدل
شيئا اي ان الدعم الامريكي استمر علينا
هنا فقط ان ننظر الى المساله كالتالي في
حال اقنعت بين مزدوجين الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل بان تتوقف عن طبيعه المعركه
الدائره الان وان تنتقل الى الى معركه
بشكل اخر من اجل الحصول على الرهائن ولكن
كذلك على اساس انه لن يكون معركه بعد
اليوم يعني ذلك بان الولايات المتحده قد
وافقت على قتل 20,000 فلسطيني وجرح 50,000
وتدمير القطاع من اجل لا شيء وهذا هذا له
ثمن اي هنا لا نتحدث عن انه اذا بالتالي
تطو تطوى الصفحه ونسير الى الامام واقع
الامر بان ه هذا التواطؤ الامريكي مع ما
اقدمت عليه اسرائيل لا ينبئ بالخير فيما
يتعلق بهذا الكلام المستجد حول امكانيه
اعاده النظر بطبيعه الحرب وحول كيفيه
اداره القطاع بعد انتهاء المعركه واقع
الامر بان كل هذا حقيقه يبقى وكانه محاوله
تبديد وتشتيت واقناع الحلفاء والشركاء
بانه ثمت افكار تطرح وثمت تشجي ولكن في
نهايه المطاف على الارض التدمير الممنهج
مستمر ولا يعرقله ال الا الصمود الفلسطيني
وهو على مستوى المقاومه وعلى مستوى
المجتمع الفلسطيني مرتفع جدا وغير مرتقب
بعد هذه اطول حرب تقضها اسرائيل واقل
نتائج تنجزها الاله القاتله الاسرائيليه
رغم رغم الدعم الامريكي غير المشروط اذا
نعم اسرائيل بحاجه الى تبديل المسار ولكن
لا لا نستطيع الاطمئنان الى هذا الحوار
بين المتواطئين لتبديل المسار لكن هل
نتوقع من هذه الزياره ان تناقش ما تريده
تل ابيب ام
واشنطن واضح جدا ما يريده نتنياهو
نتنياهو ابتدا بالحديث عن انه بالاضافه
الى الهدفين الرئيسيين القضاء على حماس
قتل حماس كما هو يقول ولا نعلم ما يعني
ذلك تحديدا قتل القاده قتل المقاتلين قتل
كافه العاملين في حماس هذا كان هو الهدف
الاول الهدف الثاني هو تحرير الرهائن ولكن
الهدف الثالث وهو المقلق جدا العمل على ان
لا يعود القطاع باي شكل من الاشكال مصدر
خطر لاسرائيل مع التدمير الممنهج الذي
شهدناه في في في القطاع فهمنا بان ذلك
يعني تحديدا نكبه في غزه نكبه لغزه اي
ترحيل الغزاويين طوعيا كما جرى تسريب
مؤخرا وهو في المرحله الاخيره بدا نتنياهو
يعيد الكلام عن هذا وبدا التسريب الاعلامي
بشان والولايات المتحده لا
تعارض التهجير الطوعي اي ان اذا شاء
الغزوي الرحيل فليكن اذا نحن هنا لا
نستطيع ان نتامل خيرا في مواقف خاصه من
الليكود ومن فريق نتنياهو بانه سوف يعمد
الى تهدئه تكون على اساس الاقرار بالحق
الفلسطيني الاقرار بالحق الفلسطيني يكون
نتيجه المقاومه نتيجه الصمود على الارض
وليس نتيجه استفاقه ووعي من الجانب
الامريكي المبادره بيد نتنياهو الذي كان
دائما ما يتفاخر بانه يستطيع اقناع
الامريكيين وتوجيههم بحسب ما
يريد سجل نتنياهو بالتعامل مع الولايات
المتحده الى اليوم هو سجل يستطيع حقا ان
يفتخر به لانه كلما اتخذ هو موقفا واتخذت
الاداره الامريكيه بغض النظر عن من فيها
من بايدن وصولا الى الى كيربي اتخذت موقفا
مغايرا للموقف الذي يتخذه نتنياهو نرى بان
ان موقف الاداره هو الذي يتبدل وليس موقف
نتنياهو اذا نعم هو قادر على على الدفع
بهذا الاتجاه ولا يزال ولكن المساله هي هل
هو قادر على تنفيذ ما يريده على الارض من
الواضح جدا بانه غير قادر الازمه في
اسرائيل اليوم ليست ازمه يمين ويسار علينا
ان نلاحظ حتى من يطالب باولويه لاطلاق
سراح الرهائن لا يقول ثم الاقرار بحق
الفلسطينيين او بالدولتين والى ما هنالك
لا هو يقول ثم افعلوا ما شئتم اي نتنياهو
لا يزال عندما يقول بانه هو يستطيع ان
يتعامل مع الامريكيين لان من هم على يمينه
ليسوا ليسوا قله على الاطلاق لا اتحدث فقط
عن بنفير وعن سموتريتش اتحدث عن كل من يرى
بان ما جرى في السابع من تشرين يشكل تهديد
وجو لاسرائيل وبالتالي لابد من حلول جذريه
ما هي هذه الحلول حقيقه اسرائيل لا تبدو
قادره على هذه الحلول لذلك هي تعول على
دعم ومساعده من الولايات المتحده بشان وصح
ان تعول على دعم ومساعده من الفلسطينيين
من خلال نديه ولكن طبعا هذا الكلام تباوي
خرافي اليوم ان اتحدث عن تفاعل فلسطيني
اسرائيلي على اساس النديه لان اسرائيل في
موطع البطش وفي موطع التعطش للدماء ولا
تزال ولكنها فاشله اشكر من واشنطن الدكتور
حسن منيمنه المحلل السياسي والباحث في
معهد الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن مش